[Music]
welcome back everyone to the data
science hangout hope you're having a
great week
and thank you to rob who covered for me
while i was out in park city last week
snowboarding
matthias i heard there was a great
session last week
if you're joining for the first time
welcome it's great to meet you too i'm
rachel i'm the host of the data science
hangout
this is an open space for the whole data
science community to connect and chat
about data science leadership
questions you're facing and what's going
on in the world of data science
i'm just going to let people in from the
waiting room real quick
if you ever want to go back and
re-watch or share a session with someone
who's missed it we do have a data
science hangout site now off of our
studio.com i'll share it in the chat in
just a moment too
we really want this to be a space where
everybody can participate and we can
hear from everyone so there's three ways
to ask questions
you can
jump in live by just raising your hand
on zoom
you can put questions in the zoom chat
and feel free to just put a little star
at the end of your question if you want
me to read it out loud if you're like in
a coffee shop or something
and then we also have a slido link that
i'll share in just a moment here too
where you can ask questions anonymously
as well
and we really love this dialogue that
happens live during the hangouts too so
i love hearing people jump in live
if you do find yourself
super inspired and spoken a few times
maybe just consider holding back a bit
for others to jump into so we want to
try and make this as inclusive as
possible and making room for others is
an important aspect of that
so just want to reiterate that we love
to hear from everyone no matter your
level of experience or area of work as
well
but with all of that i'm so excited to
be joined by my co-host for today
mike miller vp and data science team
leader at engine
and mike i'd love to turn it over to you
to just introduce yourself and maybe
tell us a little bit about the work that
you do
yeah sounds good yeah happy to be here
thanks for uh
you know inviting me and getting the
opportunity to chat with you all so
like uh rachel said i'm mike miller i'm
the vp of our data science group at
engine insights so engine group um it's
kind of our i guess our parent company
so we have three
really kind of main arms so emx which is
our
digital like ad server and programmatic
um arm and then we have an agency group
which does kind of typical marketing
campaigns and creative development and
things like that and then our insights
group which
i'm a part of
is kind of our market research and
primary research arm um you know it's
kind of built on you know survey
research and things like that so
within um my department our data science
group so there's about eight of us um i
kind of handled the data science and you
know some data engineering capabilities
um you know our main role is is advanced
analytics uh consulting methodology of
um primary research so a lot of proposal
work that we come through we help you
know design a methodology what the you
know what's going to solve the business
need
you know what techniques do we need to
you know run and you know do regressions
or
you know conjoint work
choice-based modeling things like that
so what's the right methodology and kind
of strategy to solve the business need
you know obviously has some strategic um
you know
perspective and kind of future thinking
for a lot of our key accounts you know
kind of planning out you know 2022
what's you know they got you know their
budget they're trying to do x y and z
you know so plan out
what's the proper cadence or what's the
proper um you know sequence of of
research you know maybe it's the
segmentation then we build on you know
product optimization and activation
um so kind of just strategic partners
and thinkers
you know across
you know marketing and product
development and you know customer sat
work
cx engagement stuff
so really you know full custom
research uh we do a lot of
you know innovation as well as kind of
our group is is really driven to you
know drive product development you know
it's not really necessarily creating new
products but looking at different ways
or unique ways to use
tried and true methods um data
integration's a big you know kind of
push over the past couple years of
leveraging
you know different data sources whether
that's you know client crm data whether
that's um you know online
you know search for likes online
behaviors through cookies and ipmatch
and things like that
to just you know keep enriching our data
you can only ask so much stuff in a
survey so leveraging client data
or you know third party you know data
that's available for sale um to just
integrate that stuff and drive richer
outcomes and richer data and you know
kind of tell a more colorful story so
you know that's kind of our um our remit
um you know a lot of our our stuff is
kind of you know data stewardship you
know what's the proper use of data
what's you know you're waiting and
you know when to wait when not to wait
you know what are the bounds of waiting
efficiencies and things like that um you
know obviously with statistics it's kind
of the easiest way to lie so you know
maintaining
you know maintaining quality research
and making sure the data is actually
telling what it is because it's very
easy for
you know our internal clients and even
external clients say you know the data
seems to suggest that well it might seem
to suggest that but it you know it's not
necessarily saying that it's not the
question asked it's not
spirit behind the question so
you know just to maintain your data
quality maintain your engines you know
quality and
you know not misleading our clients to
say hey you know you might look stupid
if you want to take that leap that's
fine like that's on you but
that's kind of not you know our
you know our recommendation um so
data stewardship is really kind of a
core
aspect of what our team does and what
engine strives to do is you know kind of
inform you know quality data practices
quality research
you know data quality is a huge thing
right now with
you know cheaters and stuff with general
survey research so you know maintaining
data quality initiatives and
things like that so
um i guess i can talk a little bit about
um
you know how we use r in our studio i
think the main you know tools that we
use within our department
our
you know excel spss r and python we do a
lot of work with
shiny for like online simulators and
deliverables and things like that for
you know interactive um
interactive deliverables that we give to
our client you know kind of lives on and
allows the research to kind of have more
shelf life um it allows our clients to
kind of
you know basically teach them to fish to
kind of more self-sufficient um
you know and creating things like that
for them
to click in and push and click through
the research and things like that so
it has been a great tool for us
so nice can i ask you when you say data
stewardship um
could you explain a bit more of what
that means or just provide an example of
yeah i mean i think it's just
you know
like leveraging the data in the proper
way you know there's
a lot of times you know we tried to use
our census boundary so going into a
survey we'll use kind of census targets
to make sure the data is is
representative
whether it's representative census
representative of you know a client
target market or whatever it is um so we
try to balance that stuff on the front
end so we don't have to wait very often
um but a lot of times clients will try
to just
wait to a story um you know hey you know
this
maybe you know rural is is too low and
we think we you know are getting bad
results because there's
you know rural
demographic doesn't answer the question
properly or like hey can we kind of wait
that so there's a lot of kind of
situations there that clients seem to
want to tell a story that maybe the data
doesn't suggest so obviously there's
ways to
to tell that story um to manipulate the
data a little bit so
you know it's it's our kind of
responsibility to say hey like you can
weight it to
certain bounds or you gotta you know
what's your universe you're trying to
wait to um you can't just wait to be
waiting um if your data doesn't tell you
the story
and that i mean that's helpful you know
a lot of times
you know with primary research it's it's
a difficult conversation you spent you
know fifty sixty hundred thousand
dollars on research and they didn't get
the answer they want but
you know a lot of times that hundred
thousand dollars that you spent on a
research study you maybe saved you
millions of dollars before you launched
a product so
well it didn't give you the answer you
want you're still in the long term
probably saving money or okay we need to
reoptimize we need to
change our
product change pricing to you know
whatever the recommendation may come out
of the research
you know is is helpful but a lot of
times clients don't want that answer
they want they think they know what the
story should be and it's really kind of
hey where to run this the the survey or
the research project for validation
maybe that validation doesn't happen so
yeah there's there's some conversations
around hey you know can i how do i make
that story come out like do i do i drop
data do i drop these people
um
for one given reason maybe it's data
quality issues that they think may not
have answered question right um so it's
just
you know kind of managing those
conversations you know making sure the
data you know as long as we design and
field and do the data you feel the
survey properly you know there shouldn't
be any flaws in the data and if the data
is telling a particular story you know
there's no real grounds to
manipulate it or weight it in a way that
you think it should go to try to tell
your story so
you know and also you know some of the
the findings even with analysis of
you know running some analysis and maybe
taking leaps with you know simple you
know example of correlations you know
correlations don't cause you know isn't
causality so while there's a correlation
doesn't mean that
you know a is driving b you know there's
it's a correlation so
here just those kind of things and
helping a lot of our clients are not
statistical people you know they're
marketers they're
you know product developers or things
like that so you know they're not
strong in statistics so it's really kind
of teaching them and making sure they
understand what the results are telling
them and encouraging them to not
you know step out of those those
assumptions um to kind of run with the
analysis that may you know the
statistical method doesn't really
you know validate that it doesn't
support those claims outside of its you
know general assumptions
thanks mike i i think it might be
helpful for all of us to like put us in
the
like your frame of mind too to
understand a bit about engine and like
the
clients that you are working with
um yeah
so uh i mean like i said we you know
full custom so a lot of our our studies
um i kind of grew up with you know i i
came from memories which was then bought
by rc which is now part of engine you
know so i kind of cut my teeth on cpg so
we did a lot of
you know cereals and
um
you know snacks and chips and different
things the general um
you know product optimization a lot of
it's you know sometimes it's cost
cutting can we reduce you know the the
size of a given item and without people
really knowing so
you know a lot of new product
development what's you know what's the
flavor you know does it does it mean you
know perceptions of flavor do people
like it was it a test of control or
changing a
you know a sugar content or we're
changing you know some kind of recipe
and do people notice a difference
without you know alienating
we do a lot of insurance work um you
know
home auto
health insurance
um so just managing your developing
products you know how hey if we want a
deductible at two thousand dollars
what's be the take-up rate versus you
know five thousand dollars um so some of
that product optimization
um we do a lot of like customer
satisfaction so like brand health
trackers so just kind of keeping the
pulse on the brand
a lot of cx experience so customer
experience
work um you know if you go into a store
it was it easy to find what you're
looking for a customer service good
you know kind of that stuff that you
know some urgent care work we just did
last week
you know your experience at urgent care
did you have a long wait time you know
where you had a you know courteous
receptionist you know was a nurse
courteous and helpful was the doctor you
know helpful and courteous did you get
what you needed you know was your
insurance covered so just general
experience that you know pick an
industry we've probably touched it um
yeah we do some like durable goods yeah
some like durable goods is kind of one
of our main clients like sweeper
and development things like that so a
lot of that's new product innovation
um you know prototypes and you know new
new uh new devices to the market so
you know a lot of conjoint work so if we
you know have a product line if we add
something new what does that do to the
product line it was it increment you
know is it incremental um or is it
catalyzing certain things and then
developing the price pricing strategy
across that line of items um you
potentially even stealing chair from
specific you know competitors or things
like that so
um you know the gamut of what we touch
is
is wide which you know i think is is a
big appeal for why i enjoy my job is you
know it's the same techniques the same
kind of solutions but it's you know a
ton of different industries you kind of
learn enough to be dangerous in many
different things um so the variety is is
very appealing to me so yeah
that's cool i've definitely noticed was
it's interesting when you talk about
like products like asking if people will
notice if they have
like reduced the size of it i've
definitely started to notice that during
coven
i was like yeah if you you start to see
things you know change or like the
recipe or
things are slightly like yeah i
recommended that because people didn't
notice so
yeah so it's kind of like you know you
get the back seat of
you know product development and
you know you go out to the market you're
buying these products that you
recommended to
you'll reduce the size and keep the
price so it's kind of interesting
nice i see there's a few anonymous
questions that are coming in right now
and
one was are you feeling the challenges
of hiring right now
i am um we actually just so we had two
open positions probably since
well september maybe um and we just
filled one we have one open but we're
kind of just passively um
recruiting for that right now i'm not
really sure exactly the skill set we
want because like i said we play
a little bit of in the traditional
research um you know statistical market
research you know maybe more data
science then we also have some
new data engineering capabilities so
managing
larger databases we don't have a lot of
that so we have probably one guy that's
really core to our data engineering team
um
but we don't really have a ton of that
work we'd love to get you know more get
our hands on more you know data sets and
larger data and you know kind of do more
typical data engineering tasks but
you know it's the chicken nda like do we
need to hire so we can do more of that
or do we need to do more of that before
we hire somebody and justify the cost so
we're kind of figuring out what that
second skill set should look like um but
yeah i mean we
we struggled for probably a month or two
to even find good candidates we found
really good candidates that you
know felt that they were in range we got
the offer stage they had another offer
that was completely out of our range
they accepted another offer so that
happened two or three times
we got some
resumes that kind of
passed the initial screener through hr
they get on a call with like a technical
member of our team and couldn't even you
know answer the simplest questions so
you know some resumes like yeah these
look really good but they can't talk to
talk um you know we've we've had to
change our kind of initial screening
criteria many times like
you know we we got on you know an hour
interview and we were basically done in
15 20 minutes so
yeah hiring has been a you know a
challenge that's frankly how i kind of
got connected with rachel of um you know
where i was meeting with kalau or our
studio contact and just kind of
mentioned hey like we're really
struggling like are you connected with
any
you know our communities or different
things that kind of post different jobs
and
um you know i i met rachel through that
kind of connection um but yeah
definitely
definitely struggling to you know
fill positions even get reliable
um
you know i guess qualified interviews um
and then you know the good candidates
have multiple interviews or multiple
offers that
you know
we lose for one reason or another you
know it could be salary it could be
opportunity could be
you know the the location of our
business um in cincinnati but we have a
new york chicago
based office but we're all kind of
working remote now so you know remote
you know um situation is certainly open
now with coven and everything's you know
kind of more accustomed to that
but yeah so definitely hiring has been a
challenge for
various reasons
i know you mentioned you changed the
screening process a little bit are there
other like
tips or things you could share with us
through that problem
yeah i mean not really i mean i think
our job post has largely stayed the same
um
you know i think it was you know we just
started to add some like qualifying
questions that our recruiter
could kind of ask but you know
you know they weren't too technical
because obviously she's not a data
scientist so like if they gave a
response like would she know exactly
what they're talking about or like so we
kind of have basic qualification
questions that you know we kind of armed
her with like here's a question here's a
general answer as long as they don't
like i have no idea what you're talking
about like would be a red flag so
you know that has worked well i mean
we've still got on calls where people
like yeah i really know python i really
know are and you know our
our kind of technical
person on our team would kind of ask the
interview and they're like oh i don't
even know what a regression is or i
don't know how to do that or i would
just google it was was you know one
guy's answer to many questions so i just
google it i google it
which is fine you know we certainly
google a lot but you know some of the
basic questions of
you know how do you manage a database or
how do you create a table how do you run
you know frequencies of things oh i
google it well we need more of a
foundation than that so
yes
i see um ethan you had asked a question
in the chat would you want to ask that
one
live um oh yes hello everyone this is my
probably second time
joining um
yeah
um very nice one so
incidentally i work in a very similar
company you know we also do
consulting and market research and
inside so
online simulators and control and work
is one of the things we do quite often
and i'm just curious about how do you go
about managing
and maintaining those simulators
especially you know when you have to
deal with credentials and login you know
some clients are used to having a single
login to a platform where
they have access to all the insights and
dashboard
yeah
yeah so um typically we'll do it right
through shiny server so we have a shiny
server pro account
um through our studio and um we
basically have a server locally that we
hosted on and
we provide credentials to
you obviously our internal teams and
then our clients you know maybe three
four people that get logging credentials
they go to a website you know we provide
the link and publish the
basically the entire our you know
package and the app and everything to
that server and you know provide it with
a link and and they get access to that
we've also explored
um
i don't know we've actually executed
this yet but we have dapper c
for kind of online reporting and things
like that for dashboards and kind of
ongoing things
i believe we've explored it i don't know
if we've actually delivered one but um
kind of leveraging dapper c to host some
of the shiny server stuff as well so if
they already have a diversity portal you
know to your point like they don't want
to go to multiple different things they
want to kind of one-stop shop so i think
we've
explored implementation through dapper
scene and kind of host that link um
to the shutting to the simulator and
things like that so
um you know it's been great you know i
think you know one of the main
attractions to an online deliverable is
version control you know we used to
deliver everything with excel and you
make edits or you you know add things to
it and it's hey it's version one version
two version three and you start sending
emails and different things and
it's just it's difficult to share within
the clients organizations and you know
hey is this the final one or like even
you know three four months down the road
like hey can you send me that simulator
i'm not sure how the great you know the
latest and greatest it's always on a
link and it's the same link we can
publish you know edits to it and it's
still the same link so
it's been really good for reversion
control
we've actually had one of our clients
kind of regress so they used to do excel
we went to shiny now they're coming kind
of back to excel because they want kind
of that standalone
file you know i guess that's one
downside to an online deliverable is
they don't have
you know access that they can't store
they can't keep it um
you know and kind of attach it to a
given project so they've kind of come
back to excel which
is fine i mean just it has certain
limitations you know certain large
projects you know excel can't handle
there's you know functionalities that
we've built within shiny that you know
excel just can't do um but you know
they're
they're pretty basic you know there's
not many difficult things that they
typically do in their projects so it
seems to work
i guess one of the main downside with
excel is
macros and security a lot of
organizations can sort of block those
micro enabled securities and also
version as well so if you use some of
the newer fancy functions in excel
you require other people to also have
the most up-to-date version of that
yeah
there's you know certain things you
can't you know open it with a mac or
things like that so some clients have
macs and
you know just macros and excel there's
there's a lot of you know issues with
you know compatibility so
thank you and thank you sin for jumping
in live too
libby i see you asked a question in the
chat too if you want to jump in
hey hey
sure yeah um so i was wondering if as a
third party who's coming in and helping
clients with things if you ever hit
problems around
their data maturity or their security
protocols like maybe they want something
that their data maturity isn't set to
actually help them achieve through you
guys
um
frankly we don't get a lot of
client data because a lot of our
contacts
don't have access to it or can't get it
um
you know we would love you know we have
those conversations and you know they're
on board like yep yep you know but they
either a talk to finance or talk to it
or whatever like nope we're not giving
you that data or
you know don't have access to it a lot
of times it's a mess so they're like
yeah we would love to get that we'll
talk with our team and they can't get it
or it's missing so much data
that it's not helpful um
so i mean i think that's
a lot of the struggles we've run into
you know there's there's a lot of
techniques that we've explored you know
like survival analysis and and various
loyalty databases with like grocery
stores and things like that that we
would love to kind of enrich their data
and you know we have these long-standing
tractors with them
um and
you know a lot of access to that data
would would be very helpful you know
loyalty what's a loyal customer you know
it's somebody that
spends you know a certain amount of
money of their of their monthly spend
well they only have customers so like
you know they don't have lapse people
like they don't track them or
things like that so
there's just been struggles of you know
kind of marrying up the technique that
you know would be super helpful that
they just don't have the data for don't
have access to it or aren't willing to
share it so those have been some of the
main issues over
in the past couple years when we really
strive to you know use alternative data
sources you're spending
hundreds of thousands of dollars on
yearly trackers or other you know ad hoc
projects that you know we can start to
tie things together and make connections
between various studies
you know that their first party data
would be super helpful to have but
they just they don't have access to it b
aren't willing to give it or see it's
not you know it's got so much missing
data or sparsity or nobody
really knows how to manage it on their
end um
that's it's an issue
thanks mike
i see there was an anonymous question
that came in a bit earlier too that was
they said i crept on your linkedin and
see that you started as an analyst and
you're now a vice president impressive
how did that transition go and what did
you learn along the way
yeah so yeah i started um with at mrsi
as an intern um and
you know so mrs i was a cincinnati-based
you know market research firm
fairly small mom-and-pop you know cpg
kind of thing
started as an intern was hired on
full-time as an analyst
very much in the same role where kind of
our department is now
um you know we kind of wrote you know
did the did the upfront consulting
um work and and then wrote the full
report right now we don't write the full
report we just write kind of the
advanced analytics piece um you know
kind of more driven
to data and innovation and things like
that so it's a little bit morphed um
you know my background is in is in
marketing and entrepreneurship um at nku
is where i went
but you know i i'm certainly not a coder
which is kind of interesting that i'm
hearing uh you know our studio you know
data science hangout you know i i have
enough r skills to
to be dangerous i know how to read and
kind of manipulate things not really
draft it on my own um
so
you know a lot of of my role is is kind
of just you know guiding a team you know
consulting and doing kind of hey this is
how we should do it this is
you know
the statistics that you know kind of
nuts and bolts of it to actually execute
it through r um you know i i know enough
to kind of be dangerous um but you know
there's there's other people on my team
that that really justify and help me
through those things in terms of like
coding
but yeah i mean i just i kind of
you know have done you know kept taking
on you know some key accounts and you
know
continued through the ranks um you know
frankly i was probably
got here faster than i expected you know
i think due to some departures in the
company
um you know kind of fell into the role
probably i guess two years ago 18 months
ago
um but obviously you know the executive
team and everything felt comfortable
with me taking kind of the lead of the
team and
you know if
you know our team is is pretty
tight-knit so i think there's a lot of
that you know they didn't want to bring
in you know an outsider um to somebody
that doesn't really know you know
corporate culture and
the team and and kind of upset the apple
cart so i mean i think that played a
little bit of a role but
obviously you know i
exemplified the skills that the our
executive team felt comfortable with
that and kind of making the promotion
but
yeah just you know continued to
you know consult and
you know i guess you know execute and
deliver on projects that you know i've
been given so
yeah no i mean i
didn't expect to be in this role you
know out of college 10 years you know on
job you know running a data science team
was certainly not my expectation so
thanks mike when you say
you help the team consult and
and figure out how to work on certain
projects how do you go about
communicating that
to the leadership team
yeah so um
you know there's a lot of visibility you
know we're i guess uh
we're not a small company but uh we're
not a large company either so there's a
lot of transparency with um you know the
executive team you know my mentor
was
was on the you know the executive
leadership team it was basically reports
of the ceo of insights
um
he then became a manager he's now kind
of stepped back and kind of gone
part-time so i've kind of shifted you
know different roles my mentor now is
the ceo of insights so there's just a
lot of visibility a lot of access to
upper management um
and you know frankly a lot of key
accounts so
you know they're a lot of key accounts
are comfortable coming to a frankly me
and b our team that we continue to do a
good job and
deliver you know client expectations and
manage
you know their their expectations uh as
well and and continue to deliver you
know quality product and
you know i guess client service is a lot
of kind of what we pride ourselves at
engine um you know we kind of we're
small enough to have one point you know
single points of contact our clients
really get to know our teams you know so
they'll see people on meetings it's the
same kind of group of people and have
the confidence that
you know it's going to get a job the
job's going to get done but you know in
terms of
you know how the process comes in you
know they really you know proposal comes
in you know the sales team will send it
you know probably to me and then i'll
distribute it across the team so a lot
of our team is
is not necessarily vertical or industry
focused um they certainly gravitate
towards certain clients that they know
and work with frequently
but more technique based so like we'll
have
you know segmentation kind of experts
you know discrete choice experts you
know maybe cx experts um you know
certain pockets of
technique so you know depending on what
the proposal calls for you know it'll
kind of get shuffled to the various
people on the team
um and then they'll consult and say hey
this is the best way to do it you know
here's how you know how many hours we
expected it to take um and that's kind
of our role like we don't really we're
not a sales group
we kind of say hey this is
how we expect to design it this is how
we would do it here's the hours it's
going to take they put that in the
budget you know it's the sales team's
job to to sell it and close the deal and
then we kind of then execute on the back
end so you know that's kind of process
um
how projects kind of move through the
shop
nice thank you
i know you said um you work closely with
your mentor and when you moved into this
role and i was just curious how
like or you mentioned the company isn't
that huge but it's not a small company
so do you have a formal process for
mentorship or how do you go about yeah
so they um they started like kind of a
spark is what they call it you know they
have a spark talent group um that
probably started two three years ago you
know based on you know employee surveys
and things like that people kind of got
stuck or didn't you know feel
you know training was there kind of the
the importance of your career
development and things like that so they
kind of set up
spark training so they have like a
monthly you know training topic that
people can sign up for and attend and
you know some linkedin learnings and
you know various
things that they have that you can kind
of do on demand they also do like a
formal you know session with you know
here's management skills here's change
management you know topics here's
um you know goal setting things just
various kind of career management and
career development topics um
and then they've kind of identified um
along with that they've identified like
key
i guess high potential employees that
they kind of then assigned to
um
you know upper management or kind of
executive leaders as mentors um so
within that i was you know
i was
picked into high potential groups and
that kind of hr met with me like what
are you looking for what do you you know
how do you want to grow your career what
do you want out of engine and then they
kind of aligned you to you know a given
you know executive member that that kind
of you know fit those needs and could
you know fulfill that so that's how i
kind of got grouped with um rich catrone
was my original mentor
he kind of he managed broader data
operations so obviously our team
you know our script and tab group
budgeting the client so just general
data operations so i mentored with him
for probably a year 18 months
you know then you know the the departure
kind of the vice president of our group
left um
and i think frankly that was
you know the mentorship with with rich
you know
could see who i was how i was going my
career progression you know and kind of
said yeah let's let's promote mike and
let him run it um
so i think you know a lot of those
connections and a lot of those you know
mentorship and just his guidance and my
development over you know the year 18
months with him kind of led me to that
role
once he became a manager that kind of
then said okay you know what else what's
the next step how do you want to go
you'll continue progressing progressing
um an engine and that's how i kind of
got lined up with the mentor of don
simons our our ceo at insights
so i've been with him you know ever
since i kind of took the role as vice
president
but yeah it's just continued exposure to
the mx group agency group you know kind
of what's his vision of engine and how i
fit into that and
how to drive the team forward and what
he wants out of us um so
it's just it's been great you know have
him as a as a friend as a mentor
obviously he's a ceo so you've got to
kind of answer to what he wants and what
the vision of the team but
you know just have a more personal
connection with him and and you can kind
of
learn and grow and hey you know where
where do i need to improve and kind of
have
you know that that connection to
somebody that
you know
not that i necessarily want to
you know strive towards but um
you know can kind of lead me in and kind
of leadership and
you know management and
stuff like that so
yeah that's cool that you have that
program there i was curious if other
people had similar like mentorship
programs at their company i know that's
something we had like a slack channel
for here at our studio but i don't think
we had like a formal
program around it
um
so curious to hear in the chat too from
others
i am i see there's an anonymous question
too that went back to ethan's comment
and it was
thinking about ethan's comment does the
need to find individuals who are skilled
in both advanced excel
and our slash python further complicate
hiring
so i think i was just kind of looking at
the chat i think this might get ethan
your follow-up as well so within our
team we have kind of pockets of people
so like i said i
i'm by no means a programmer or coder an
r or python i know enough to be
dangerous um
but there are
you know one person that's really good
in python that's his kind of go-to
there's a handful of people that are
are good and dylan and proficient and
are
um so people really you know we're kind
of programming agnostic however you want
to get the job done get the job done if
you're comfortable in r you're
comfortable in python you're comfortable
spss or excel do that
um you know when we look for hiring it's
kind of
one of the other yeah i think a lot of
candidates we're seeing now have patent
skills um i think maybe that's more so
taught in college um
you know some people have enough
you know they know are they know how to
use it but they feel more comfortable in
python
um so
yeah i don't you know our criteria is
not to be proficient in both you know
generally our entry level positions is
just have a general foundation
if you're better in one verse the other
great that means you can kind of learn
the other if we need you to
but we don't really require um to have
all of those skills
you know i think if you know one program
in language
you can learn the other one um you know
it's kind of just kind of general
mindset yeah sure there's nuance and
things like that but
most of what we're doing isn't you know
they're not developing
code per se right out of it like from
scratch we have a lot of stuff that
you're just manipulating and editing and
tweaking and you know kind of you know
particular shiny simulators they're all
very templatized and you just kind of
manipulate various pieces you know on an
ad hoc basis on a you know given project
you know there's certainly some
development um you know there's a new
you know quirk to the
to the project or things like that um
you know there could be some development
and things like that um where you would
hopefully have some some more proficient
you know users of our and those skill
sets um
but yeah i mean we generally look for
just the general coding language i mean
i think you know when we had
the first open position we were looking
for r particularly because you know we
needed more shiny
you know skills and more proficiency in
shiny and kind of help you know we had a
gap there so that was kind of a main
focus
you know now i said with our open
position we're kind of
you know we're kind of passively looking
um you know there's not a huge rush to
fill that
but yeah i would probably stand some
more of a data engineering role so maybe
more python based
um you know azure and cloud computing
and things like that it's kind of a
maybe the gap or the lean part of the
team right now so
like i said again like we don't have an
immediate need for that so that's kind
of you know passive looking we're
starting actually a
an atp uh associate training program i
think in april or may so kind of more
entry level people that across the
company so various departments will kind
of go through and
and learn
you know here's how
this department works that department
works and kind of get a general
understanding of many different
departments um so we're kind of maybe
waiting a little bit for that so that
project or when that
program kicks up and i think april or
may that they would kind of maybe be in
a couple weeks or so before that and
kind of jump into that program fresh
so yeah that's kind of
i guess our hiring plan right now
that um
associate training program is that so
that's something that came from
like leaders yeah so that came from
spark so that's been going actually a
couple years um which i was actually on
kind of development team and kind of the
execution of that in the first probably
two to three years and what
what does our data science
department in general need from it like
what does that look like you know how do
we what basic understanding do people
not on our team
should they have of data science how do
we operate it's really just these are
the things you should be aware of if you
hear you know now you have a basic
understanding or hey i heard that
buzzword or whatever it is loop in the
data science team you know let the
detectable experts kind of handle those
conversations so it's really just kind
of awareness thing
um
you know it's it's morphed and changed
you know
no training programs perfect so you know
we've created
you know kind of real projects and
things for the
the
associates to kind of learn and this is
how our project works here's the
insights here's what data looks like you
know because most of them are fresh out
of college and
you know various roles and various
backgrounds where they came from so it's
here's what a data table looks like
here's you know here's what our
regression output looks like here's how
to pull
your findings and things out of you know
these analysis and then tell a story and
create a report and you know how to
deliver that and you know present and
give those skills
to kind of those people fresh out of
college
it's great that you have that i know on
these conversations a lot of times we've
talked about how like time intensive it
is to actually train people and bring
people on board yeah so originally it
was actually like an eight-week program
that you came in and you did this
program for eight weeks and then
we kind of got feedback from
you know those various managers of those
those individuals say hey like i hire
somebody and then i don't get them on my
team for eight weeks like that kind of
doesn't work so
we've we've morphed it a little bit of
you know it's still an eight week
program but basically you get
you know probably two or three days of
training you know maybe the mornings are
you know sessions with trainers and
things like that and kind of walk
through presentations there's some
homework and just general you know
projects to work on and things like that
you can kind of fit in on various
afternoons that we kind of block
schedule or block time off for them but
then like the rest of the remaining
probably half of the week is them to
really on board with their respective
team you know to to help carry the load
obviously if they've been hired that
team needs support so
um yeah they can start to kind of fall
into that role and do
you know client work and things like
that so
nice
i see there was another anonymous
question that was how do you build
comfort talking to and sharing work with
executives
yeah i mean so a lot of our like our
projects are set up that everybody has
every project has a primary and
secondary analyst so you're always with
somebody um there's all whether it's
your manager whether it's somebody else
um
that knows that client knows that
project you know or methodology
um but it's really just kind of you know
learned over the years it's you know i
maybe i'm a silent listener little
silent listener for a while and just
kind of hear the flow hear how things
work here the presentation style
you know it's a lot of times it's
learning the
you know the
the tendencies or kind of preferences of
our internal sales people learning the
preferences of giving clients what they
want what they expect how they you know
are they
technical at all do they know you know
any statistical methods do they have no
understanding of any of that so kind of
you can speak technical or you cannot so
it's really learning
the tendencies and preferences um kind
of in a safe zone you know you're kind
of a silent listener or somebody else is
doing it then you get oh here's a slide
or two for you then it's okay you're
running the meeting on your own then
it's you know then you start to kind of
be that person with you know a shadow
behind you that you're kind of hey do
this and maybe i'll present it or
you know you just start to kind of
you know learn and adapt and kind of
learn the style and just get that
comfort level i mean there was many
times that
you know early in my career that
you know i
you know traveled to
a given client i was there by myself or
i was with somebody and hey you're going
to present this workshop you got all day
thing and like oh [ __ ] like
that's super scary like
you know i don't know how i'm gonna do
with that but you just kind of get
thrown into it and you think you know
not necessarily you're gonna sink or
swim but you know your manager that
person who kind of puts you in that
position knows you're gonna succeed you
know is there to kind of
fill in the gap you get off track or
don't know how to answer a question you
know it's it's kind of those tendencies
i know how if you don't know the answer
just i don't know the answer i'll look
it up i'll get back to you you know
don't don't make it up so it's just
learning those
soft skills learning those presentation
skills
um you know certainly being in
uncomfortable positions um and then
you know as a manager you kind of learn
that like you're gonna grow with
challenges so you know kind of put
people in positions that they're gonna
succeed it might be uncomfortable for
them but
you know i have the confidence in my
team or my junior people that they're
gonna do the right thing or i wouldn't
put them in in that position so
you know it's just it's the comfort once
you do it once it's like oh okay that's
not so bad you know as i kind of moved
in the vice president role i presented
more conferences and things like that
and it's like oh okay yeah i can present
a conference i've done that you know i
know the
i know the the information i know the
i know the materials i'm presenting so
just you know it's the
anxiety or the fear of talking in front
of people but like you know the subject
matter just you know you got to start
doing it
so
thank you that's super helpful it and i
think just
with working with so many different
industries too you have to know about so
many different right i mean yeah we had
a like a 3d printer client you know came
to us and i was like i don't know
anything about 3d printing and
you just start googling you learn about
their business you ask questions you
know
you know we're market research we're not
3d printers we're not engine engineers
so it's like hey like i don't really
know your industry like how does this
work like hey talk a little bit more
about what you're trying to do you know
we're trying to optimize a product or a
printer for them
and it's like i don't i don't know how
that works like i don't know anything
about it so you just kind of start to
ask
you know might be stupid questions but
it's like i they can't expect you to
know their business you know you're
trying to help them they're coming to
you for things that they don't know how
to do so
you know it's a give and take it's just
that comfort level to ask the stupid
question um and most of the time like
yeah you know that's it's a great
question here's how we do it so
you know there's there's certainly
things that
industries are like i don't know
anything about that and you just kind of
research it you know google it you know
there's you know ask questions of your
client internal client team that you
know maybe they've had a long-standing
relationship with this client that kind
of know that industry
or just ask your clients you know
there's they can't expect you to know
everything about their business
yeah that's a good point and it's making
me think about like how we all even work
with our own internal clients or
different departments across our own
companies too
i see there's um
an interesting chat going on right now
as well javier and libby around
like the responsibility of consultants
as well um xavier i don't know if you'd
be
open to jumping in and sharing that
comment as well
yeah i mean my comment was more
just to follow up to libby's question it
was uh
when i was in consulting i was pretty
much providing a very very specific
like
economic and
valuation financial service we did work
with a ton of data though and there was
a lot of modeling involved with it
my job was never to be sort of a
you know data process consultant so if
some company hired us
and 99 of the time data was garbage
it really was not my job
to try and fix the problem for them
my job was to sort of clean up the data
as best as possible
augment the data with
you know overrides or whatever it might
be to get it to a place where we felt
comfortable you know getting to an end
result that was reasonable
so
um
you know i i don't know how many other
data consultants nowadays nowadays are
in the same situation
um
where it's like you're providing a
specific service maybe a specific
statistical study
maybe the end result is you know a live
shiny app that you're gonna deploy for
some customer
um
and if that's the end result
maybe you know you shouldn't really
worry too much about the process of
how
the client collects or tracks their data
and you know just
focus more on how can we clean up their
data that needs to be used for the
analysis that you're doing
yeah yeah i mean i would completely
agree with that you know i think we
we consult sometimes like you know we've
done some segmentations
that it was built on on primary survey
data
but they also want to tag their database
so like if we
maybe their database has age gender some
other you know psychographics and things
like that of their general business
consumer
you know maybe we you know can help them
tag their database but you know again
like they may have that data they may
have sparse data um but it's like hey
you know
this is how we can deal with it you know
maybe you can add some fields your your
sales force data or something like that
to kind of continue to collect and help
you kind of moving forward but
yeah i mean i don't think many times
that we speak hey this is how you should
be doing it or you know generally kind
of what you said javier is
you know maybe we're using 10 variables
maybe has some missing data sure we can
impute some data or you know some
percentage of data and we'll kind of do
the best we can with the data we need
and
you deliver that analysis and then you
know
the rest of their data problems are kind
of their problems you know we can kind
of help consult and say hey
it would be great if you could add these
data fields going forward it might help
your business might help
you know lead some insights based on
what analysis we've done that these are
key predictors
um but yeah we don't get a ton into
this is how you fix your data issues
yeah
mike just curious what's the typical
duration of your engagements
um
i would say a typical project's probably
six to eight weeks
you know for a general ad hoc um you
know a lot of our
more key accounts or things like that
it's kind of just an ongoing thing you
know it's kind of strategic consulting
or you know planning you know it's it's
general conversations you know a lot of
clients we have standing meetings of you
know weekly or bi-weekly of just hey
what's going on yeah hey we got this
project you know hey again you know okay
that one's going up it's up and running
we're kind of getting to the end hey we
got these other projects in mind or
we're trying to you know plan you know
budgets and and what should we do
what's the sequence of different
projects but yeah generally at six to
eight weeks you know we have some
ongoing trackers that you know are
fielded weekly monthly quarterly
so i mean those just are continuing
in general
cadence of reporting uh there's
certainly longer ones you know maybe
segmentation runs a little bit longer
um because there's a lot of you know
iteration through that and workshopping
with the client so hey we get here's a
first draft here's what we're seeing
this is what we think you know does that
kind of jive or maybe there's multiple
solutions that we kind of work through
and say hey you know this is where we
think there's here probably our
recommendation but here's a couple other
options because again we you know they
know their business you know we try to
learn as much as we can about their
business but
there's things internally there's
internal champions you know ceo might
want x y and z
that we're just not proving to so
you know some of the the more advanced
or kind of larger projects maybe those
are 10-12 weeks
you know it really kind of depends on
you know i think the biggest
um
the biggest kind of time thing is
developing the questionnaire we just did
a major global segmentation across 33
countries it took us nine months to get
the project to get the survey fielded it
was across you know
33 plus you know every country probably
had its own language some countries had
multiple languages so a lot of
translation and things like that and
approvals from legal departments and
stuff like that so i mean it took us
nine months to get the project up and
going and then we you know collected um
collected data for probably
two-ish months
across all the countries and then we
delivered the analysis in about a month
so
you know it really just kind of depends
on on the scope and
a lot of times it's client approvals a
lot of times our clients on the main
hang up
you know get approvals get you know
things through
you know their stakeholders make sure
everybody's got their fingerprint on it
and they feel comfortable with it if
they're spending you know a ton of money
on it
so a lot of times it's client
you know client hang-ups
you know kind of stall out a project
i think part of your answer here
answered robert's question but i see
from the chat robert also asked is it
smart to ever decline
the engagement or lower expectations if
the industry is in a sweet spot
relative to your expertise
yeah i mean i think um
probably a couple years ago we
frankly were fairly lean in sales so we
would kind of do the best we could to
bid on it um you know i think now we're
certainly in a better spot but you know
we just somewhat did that
a couple weeks ago you know we just
didn't feel that we could do it on the
timeline with the scope and the project
we kind of put our best foot forward and
said hey here's what we can deliver you
know maybe we delivered on one of their
three primary objectives but you know
it's just transparent you know hey this
is what we can do and to solve x it's
not going to do
you know a b and c
and you know ultimately we we didn't get
awarded the project but we kind of knew
that we frankly didn't really want the
project but i mean it's one of our our
long-standing clients you know they come
to us probably two three projects to
propose on a month and you know this one
we just
didn't feel comfortable with what they
were doing what they're you know we
couldn't we couldn't address everything
in one study um
you know effectively and at the price
point and
you know just kind of just we're
transparent said hey this is what we can
do with with this budget here's what we
can do
you know with these objectives you know
this is what you're gonna get you're not
gonna get that and if you know as long
as they're transparent i know what
they're gonna get you know kind of
protects us on the back end but yeah i
think there's been other cases that
we've not even submitted a proposal for
things or just declined um you know
because you know there's a lot of good
faith in that you know we don't want to
you know long-standing client we're not
going to say hey yeah we can do it and
then just fail deliver that's just going
to hurt the relationship in general so
mike
i i see brian you just asked a question
in the chat too if you want to jump in
yeah sure mike so
a few years back i worked in um
marketing research also
and um
how much machine learning are you doing
with the survey data i was actually able
to create some really interesting ways
to do it
um that were extremely valuable i'm just
wondering if you're finding that
are you able to do it or is this
something that you want to
try to convince your clients to accept
or do
yeah i mean it kind of depends i mean
we've done so we definitely do some
machine learning on a fairly regular
basis with um like online behavior third
party data and merging that with um
with our survey data so we do
you know kind of an ensemble approach
there's like five different algorithms
random forces
svm xg boost things like that we kind of
pick the best model of what we're doing
um
you know we've done
a you know we've done some bayesian
networks it's kind of it's kind of weird
like the research industry goes in you
know cycles like things will be hot like
segmentation we're doing a ton of
segmentation right now i think a lot of
that's firm
from covid like just the markets are
changing people are buying things
differently they're interacting with
brands differently so a lot of brands
are trying to understand how the market
has shifted so you know segmentations
are super hot right now
um you know bayesian networks were
probably hot two years ago like we did
four or five bayesian networks a year
um now we haven't touched one in two
years um so
things just go in cycles uh most of our
data
from survey research
is probably 2 000 completes or under um
and then a lot of our clients just want
to cut and slice data so you know some
some techniques are useful some are not
just with you know the the amount of
data we have um
you know i think we're we're trying to
engage with our emx team
you know in terms of programmatic um
trying to get our hands on you know
different agency clients and try to just
onboard the alternative data sources you
know as we get larger and larger data
that's where kind of machine learning
and things like that
but a lot of our bread and butter stuff
is segmentation you know through k-means
or even like sawtooth there um
like ccea so it's like an ensemble
approach of various techniques
um regroup you know basic regressions
um
you know conjoint work max stiff work um
some pricing stuff like bandwest and
you know price laddering through gabric
ranger um so that's i mean that's most
of our bread and butter um you know
we're trying to go
you know be more strategic and try to
get more data sources and things like
that which is where kind of predictive
modeling comes in um you know i think
this is frankly where the future i think
a lot of our clients they want to know
what's what's going to happen in the
future rather than what has happened in
the past which is kind of typical market
research you know is kind of
you know
backwards looking you know what happened
in the past you know a lot of clients
now are like how can i use the data from
trackers or other stuff to predict
what's going to happen or you know the
early indicators of things
so
yeah i found one thing was to change the
whole survey technique so
you can actually do a 2000 in the survey
world is a lot of responses so that um
are you using a likert scale are you
using something else
get rid of the likert scale go to one
zero to ten scale or one to ten scale
and then you'll leave binary outcomes
and you'll find logistic regression
or elasticnet will do amazing things for
you um
like a simple way to think about is nps
right you ask the nps question but then
you ask 10 follow-ups
or 9 or 8 or whatever your favorite
number is scale those 1 to 10. now
you'll be able to say hey for every
increase
in this area that you improve your mps
is going to go up or down by y
and what it also identifies is where the
problems are so we i've actually used
that for several companies and it's like
all right you got to fix this problem
they actually did they would spend
months do it next you know you do the
mps score again
three more it goes up three and a half
points and it's kind of like interesting
it works and and so it's like all right
take care of the next question but uh
the biggest thing is getting research to
get rid of like or scale
statistically it has too many problems
with it
and you'll get nice variability out of a
one to ten scale and next thing you know
i think you'll find yourself with some
really even i've done with 1200
responses and you get statistically
significant results
yeah so i mean that's you know a lot of
times it's client preference and we have
surveys that have five point scale seven
point scale ten point scale one point
scale we just had a conversation last
week with
a survey you know somebody new to their
company came on you know as most of
their servers ten point scales they
won't switch everything to 11 point
scales but maintain trending like what
does that do it's like
is there really a benefit to that like
you're just you're changing 11 or 10 to
11 for personal preference and you still
want to maintain trending but that was a
interesting conversation but yeah i mean
we actually have a simulator that's like
our cx roi
that it's all you know ten point scale
based questions logistic regression you
know for every point you know on a
independent variable you you gain x on
the dv um and then we've actually tied
that to some of their sales data so
you know for every new loyal customer
you get you're gaining you know say 500
and we kind of extrapolate that out per
thousand customers so you can kind of
get an roi feed so that's actually one
of our shiny simulators that we've
delivered um to one of our clients so
yeah
it sounds like one of your clients was a
fan of spinal tap or something like that
so they wanted to go to an 11 you know
because because it was better than 10.
yeah well i mean i guess the traditional
mps is on 11 but it's like
you know okay but you know do you want
to go to 11 just because you want to go
to 11 or you want to maintain trending
that you've done for two three years so
you know when they report in means and
they report full scale so it's like
you know there's gonna be variability
like we can do our best to kind of
calibrate it but
there's gonna be change so
good
this like survey topic i am always
curious about like what happens when i
just get very tired of a survey halfway
through like i have really good
intentions of answering it for the
company and i like the person was great
and they want like their five stars to
get through but then they just keep
going
yeah
no i i mean i mean obviously being in
this industry i'm the worst survey taker
like i hate taking surveys and like i
just pick them apart and
yeah i mean that's that's a huge problem
you know people clients particularly
like you know hey let's do this
30-minute survey and like nobody's going
to take it like you're going to get 15
minutes in and people bail so you know
respondent engagement respond to fatigue
like those are huge concerns and things
that we deal with on a daily basis you
know if you get garbage data you're
going to have garbage analysis so you
know
make sure you design it right make sure
you build a questionnaire that asks
questions that you want and you know cut
out the fluff cut to the point keep it
focused
yeah that's my that's my was my ideas
like
five questions
maybe 10 max
one of them should be a binary
more than that you better be paying your
respondents and
when you pay respondents you get a whole
different you can get a whole different
story um
but you're right i mean
survey fatigue huge issue like somebody
wanted to do one with like 20 questions
like you're wasting your time you're not
going to get anybody
you'll get like two people to finish it
um
and uh then you like where's rachel was
pointing out you got to worry about we
used to see straight liners you get the
same score all the way across all five
10 15 questions like what's the
difficult thing is like sometimes that's
logical i mean something's reasonable
that was one of the discussions like i
said is
i'm not going to remove those just
because you think that you don't unless
they tell you that somewhere in the
survey that right i mean that's a lot of
our data quality initiatives like
there's you know four or five flags and
you gotta fail two or three of them
because you know i you know it took me
you know 10 minutes to go through the
survey but i straight lined everything
okay maybe that's a logical answer you
know if somebody did a straight line or
in 30 seconds or a minute sure they're
probably cheating or it's a bot or
other things but
you know it's it's varied and that's
kind of back to data stewardship people
like oh let's throw these people out
well
there's there's indication that that's a
logical response so we're not just going
to chuck them out because we don't like
them
um that we gave to the marketing group
share it in the chat brian
i don't know can you send a file
um oh i can put it i'll put it on the
meetup you have it github
i'll put it in the linkedin
um
i was just curious to like with this
conversation about surveys if you had
any just like immediate tips for us all
even if we're like pulling our own
colleagues or
asking them about
like a shiny app that we made or
something are there tips that you have
for surveys we do internally
um
no i mean i think you know responding
fatigue is the biggest one you know ask
ask questions you know i think double
barrel questions are bad like just a
general
you know don't make sure your question
is
is
as asking what you want people to
respond to make sure there's no
way for other people to interpret it
differently um so you know a good
question is you know write the good
write the question well so you're
getting a response that people
understand what you're asking
um and just keep it short you know keep
it focused make sure you're you're
asking people what you want to get out
of it you know it's very easy to start
going down the rabbit hole i'd love to
have this date i'd love to have that
data you know every time you add a
question that's not focused on your main
objective
it's it's just fluff people are why are
you asking me this why you know it's a
five minute question well now it's a ten
minute question here because you added
five ten other questions that don't
really pertain to what you want to get
out of it
so garbage in garbage out you know i
think that's
keep it focused people you know are so
consumed with a ton of other things you
know if you can ask a
you know a five minute questionnaire and
five-minute survey
you'll get in get out um
so
thank you
i i just want to check that i didn't
miss any questions earlier from the chat
or from slido if anybody anyone wants to
jump in
give people a few more seconds here
well i think there was one question
about uh
on slido spss
uh
okay that i haven't seen that i haven't
seen that tool in a while
oh what oh i see it what do you use spss
for was the question yeah so
um basically every project that we run
has an spss file so a lot of our like
data tabulations so we run things
through dimnet which is our main like
survey platform that we you know script
and
basically serve the link to have people
complete
so that's all run through dimensions and
then that kind of exports into spss so
when our data tabulation team
creates excel
tabs and everything like that basically
creates an spss folder or an spss file
um so
you know if there's
you know correlations or regressions or
things like that it's just it's very
easy to just hop in there and run it
spss you know in my opinion has really
good kind of diagnostics i think a lot
of r and python things um you know
sometimes it just runs and gives you
minimal outputs um you know some of the
packages so
yeah there's just a lot of you know i
think
tried and true nist you know that's kind
of what i learned in college and kind of
grew up learning and you know feel
comfortable with and we still use it
because it's easy accessible we have the
licenses
um but a lot of you know it's just as
easy to export as a csv and throw it in
our python if we need it too so
um it's got data labels it's got the the
value labels right there and when we get
the file you just open it and see you
know run basic frequencies correlations
and things pretty quickly and easily so
um if people do have follow-up
[Music]
if people do have follow-up questions
though or want to connect with you is
linkedin the best place yep linkedin's
great um
you know that
easy way to connect and chat and you
know can follow up with any questions or
anything like that
perfect
well thank you so much mike for chatting
with us and sharing all your experience
really appreciate it thank you all for
joining today too
you